july inflation numbers have come out
5.4 percent cpi
and
core is at 4.3 what's your take on the
inflation numbers
well you know first of all this is the
first time this year right this is the
seventh monthly
inflation number
this the first time we didn't beat
expectations you know we actually met
expectations for a 0.5 percent
rise
but that's still a big increase
and even though it's not quite as big as
the 0.9 from the prior month
if you add up the first
seven months of the year
and then you annualize that we're at 7.2
percent
a cpi which is well above the fed's you
know target of two percent where they
say we're aiming to get a little bit
above two percent they are way more than
a little bit above two percent and these
aren't even honest numbers you know a
third of the cpi is rent and even though
rents are surging
uh the cpi only reports about a two and
a half percent uh year over year
increase so uh if we had real rents in
the cpi we'd probably be you know around
10 maybe more
so you think that the rent not being
included in a real way in the cpi number
is really uh kind of artificially
keeping that number down compared to
what it really is for the average
american
sure and that's just one way because i
think a lot of the other price
components the way they move them
through the cpi with hedonic adjustments
or weighting or geometric averaging
whatever they do they have all kinds of
sleight of hand to take a big number and
then make it into a smaller number by
the time it goes through
all the machinations that are part of
the cpi
formula so sure the average american
is
experiencing a cost of living increase
that far exceeds
what the cpi shows
and you know one of the things on rent
too
i think that the fact that there is this
eviction moratorium
this is also keeping landlords from
raising rents because the people aren't
even paying their rents because they
can't be evicted but i think once the
eviction moratorium ends and it
eventually will end i mean it's clearly
unconstitutional even the supreme court
has said it's unconstitutional uh but
eventually it's going to come to an end
and then all those pent-up rent
increases are going to happen all at
once and and you know whether or not
that gets captured in the cpi remains to
be seen but it certainly will be
experienced uh by americans who are
renting all right let's talk about used
in new cars earlier in the show we
pulled up the charts and it's just
literally going parabolic it's like off
the chart for both of them used cars up
42 percent year over year how do you
look at those kind of such outlandish
increases in prices affecting the cpi
and core inflation numbers
yeah well i mean those numbers are in
there although i i my guess would be
it's understated even though it's a big
you know part of the increase but
clearly this is the result of inflation
because the federal reserve and other
central banks can print money but they
can't mass produce automobiles right so
we're printing money faster than we're
producing cars and so that's why the
price of cars is going up now a lot of
people want to say oh you know this is
just a supply shortage inflation always
you know includes a supply shortage
because you have a demand surplus where
does the demand surplus come from
printing money you see the real way to
increase demand for cars is to produce
more cars and so when you produce more
cars the price of cars can come down in
real terms and then that can lead to
increased demand but when you increase
demand by just printing money and giving
it to people to buy cars that haven't
been produced then what happens is the
price of those cars just goes up or the
cars that have been produced and that's
what we see especially in used cars
because the used cars are already here
and so people are buying those instead
of the new cars that don't exist and
they're bidding up the prices of the
used cars
talk to us a little bit about what uh
what some would call like a shrink
flation so it's not just the increase in
price but also the idea that people are
actually delivering less goods for the
same price they keep the price the same
but they deliver less goods how does
that impact some of these numbers
well you know i have a feeling that a
lot of these decreases in quantity
are not necessarily getting captured in
the cpi these are really marketing
gimmicks because a lot of companies
would prefer
to
disguise the price increases and so the
way they do that is just they you know
they put fewer sheets of toilet paper in
the roll or they don't they put a little
less cereal in the box but they don't
raise the price and sometimes they
really try to fool the customers they
actually make the box bigger as they're
putting less cereal inside it to really
confuse you into thinking you're getting
more when you're actually ending up with
less but there's a limit to how small
they can make the packages right i mean
eventually we can't buy toilet paper by
the sheet so at some point the rolls
become so short or small it's ridiculous
and then the packaging becomes a problem
so the the the um the retailers are
going to run out of smoke and mirrors
and more of the price increases are
going to end up uh being actually higher
prices and not just uh you know smaller
quantities but i think another way that
price increases don't even get don't
even show up in the cpi
is when companies just start adding fees
for things that used to be free
and so those free things you know
weren't even part of the cpi so all of a
sudden companies start making up things
and charging you so that you're paying
money for things that you used to got
used to get for free or that were part
of the service none of that is in the
cpi because there's nothing to base it
on because it it wasn't even a component
hey guys thanks so much for watching
that clip of the best business show make
sure you like and subscribe to the
channel turn on notifications so you
know when we go live every weekday and
then head to sofi.com
so that you can get an account we can
get after it